well America and Margot um Barbie is
such an iconic toy so how does it how
does it feel like I don't know to bring
her story to life I played with Barbies
when I was a kid did y'all I did not you
did not I I was not a Barbie player were
you guys Barbie you it wasn't cool too
but I still did like secretly it was a
what'd you say it wasn't cool to play
with Barbies but I said it was like at
school you'd be like Barbie and then at
home I'd be like
yeah I don't remember having my own
Barbies but my cousin had a box of them
they were like all yes
you know the we would cut the hair and
do all that stuff but I got the fold out
house one Christmas when I was young and
that was every I was a Barbie dreams the
dream house that folded out like
honestly coming into this movie it was
like that was that was such a priority
it was those the sets and then getting
them getting to see them be built right
in front of us and they were just huge
real life versions of the dream house it
looks incredible so amazing and so
beautiful and it's like the first thing
I said to gretels you know when we first
sat down talked about the movie I was
like I'll follow your vision whatever
you want this Barbie movie to be like
let's do that except I just have one
favor please please please can we have a
dream house where she has a slide that
goes from her bedroom down to her
because that is my goal in life she was
like yeah sure that's your thing that's
your thing and I was like yes that's not
like your character Arc like I thought
you were going big or even the tone of
the movie none of that I was just like I
just want that slide it's so bad oh my
God I'd love that I I think I'm older
than all of you so I loved I was
obsessed with Barbies like it was the
cool thing whenever I was a kid now back
like I don't like back then I mean to be
perfectly honest one of the reasons I
didn't play with Barbie is because like
it didn't I didn't feel reflected in the
world of Barbie you know it was a very
Americana version of beauty and like
maybe there was a one black Barbie and
there were white Barbies but now it's
totally different and like to be invited
to get to be a part of this narrative
where like Barbie is represents so many
more people yeah it's like it's the it's
the Barbie we deserve you know and
that's what's it's so moving to get to
be a part of this reimagining of this
world of beauty and fun and aspiration
where more of us get to be seen
absolutely it's cold
it's cool too and you have kids because
it's like it's come back around like in
such a big way like my all my little
girl her friends they all have Barbies
they're obsessed every time she's like I
want the car I want the Jeep she's like
I'm like wait for a holiday
um but it's just it's not Tuesday don't
get it every day
um so but anyway it's it's really cool
though to see her playing and doing the
same stuff that I did whenever I was a
kid but yeah it's cool to see her kids
like I wonder if your kids will get into
it but my my daughter is like really
into Barbies or not and when I walk in
girl she's got them kissing just like
you just said she's like I'm like Barbie
she's like they were kissing mom get out
it was like okay
um did you play with Barbies I was I was
Barbie curious there were Barbies
in the home my my sister had a lot of
Barbies and they
they had diagnoses these bar I mean
these Barbies were messed up at her hand
you know and she but they were there and
she she had spent hours with her friends
uh doing the most to me I mean it was
like her training as a comedian and a
theater artist she like yeah uh came up
with all these amazing things and built
an entire world out of them and I
thought wow that's really cool
you're really cool I love my sister I'll
say it here I'll stay here right now
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]